[Music]
welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody Superstar Ed Sheeran defended
one of his most popular songs thinking
out loud in a New York courtroom on
Tuesday he's accused of copying elements
of the iconic song Let's Get It On by
Marvin Gaye Ed Townsend helped gay right
let's get it on in the 1970s but his
daughter Catherine Townsend Griffin is
the one now suing Ed Sheeran in Atlantic
record saying the pop star's song has
quote striking similarities to what
Townsend and gay created decades ago
it's not the lyrics the jury will
consider in this copyright fight no it's
the actual Melody the harmony the rhythm
of the songs based on the sheet music
Marvin Gaye's estate is not involved in
this lawsuit but as you might know has
previously won a copyright infringement
case against Robin Thicke Pharrell
Williams and T.I for the song Blurred
Lines during opening statements civil
rights attorney Ben Crump showed video
of a concert where Sheeran sang thinking
out loud and moved effortlessly into
Let's Get It On sheer encountered that
he often sings different mashups at his
shows during his testimony Sharon said
quote if I'd done what you're accusing
me of doing I'd be an idiot to stand on
stage in front of 20 000 people and to
do that it's my belief that most pop
songs are built on building blocks that
have been freely available for hundreds
of years Sharon actually recently won a
copyright case in the UK in early 2022
he went to court in London over his song
Shape of you two songwriters accused him
of stealing parts of their song called
oh why after the judge ruled in his his
favor Sheeran put out a video statement
on Instagram
whilst we're obviously happy with the
result I feel like claims like this are
way too common now and have become a
culture where a claim is made with the
idea that a settlement will be cheaper
than taking it to court even if there's
no base for the claim it's really
damaging to the songwriting industry
there's only so many notes and very few
chords used in pop music coincidence is
bound to happen if 60 000 songs are
being released every day on Spotify as
22 million songs a year and there's only
12 notes that are available
Brian the video of Ed Sheeran doing that
mashup of Let's get it on and thinking
out loud I feel like that might be a
Smoking Gun is that incredibly helpful
for the plaintiffs I mean your thinking
is the same thing that Ben Crum said
that this is the Smoking Gun in the case
now I would say it's not necessarily A
Smoking Gun it's more of a spark it's
helpful in front of a jury for sure to
see him do it and admit to being able to
blend the two songs together his
explanation of how the song was made
does happen between him and his
co-writer just kind of rifting off of
each other his explanation of his
ability to do this being that he can
blend one song together I think Cuts
both ways he is a great artist but
saying it was closer to Van Morrison's
song that was a huge plot twist I really
think it's going to come down to these
12 jurors to see what their common sense
is based on what Ben Crump is arguing
but also to see what the argument that
Sharon is making to see if it makes
sense well Terry you were in court today
and then you were there when the
plaintiffs played an AI version of
Marvin Gaye's song Let's Get It On what
was the Court's reaction to that well
interestingly enough it was the oddest
thing I've ever heard and the court
thought so too everybody actually
chuckled I looked at the jury and the
jury was sort of smiling but in the
courtroom everyone was more than smiling
they were actually chuckling and the
reason they had to do the AI version was
because they filed with the copyright
office what's called a deposit sheet and
that deposit sheet really just included
chord progression so they couldn't play
the whole song but they tried to compare
let's get it on with Ed Sheeran's song
and so thinking out loud they played Ed
Sheeran's song so when you played the AI
against Ed Sheeran's song it really did
sound different I actually spoke to
Catherine Gifford and asked her what she
thought about the AI she said she
thought it was a little bit
disrespectful so I'm sure they thought
they wish they could play the real song
all right Terry we got to get you back
in that courtroom coming up on Long
crime daily we're looking at two big
cases in the hip-hop world Repertory
Lanes fights for a new trial out in Los
Angeles and rapper Young Thug's Rico
trial is very slowly chugging along plus
there's a theme playing a major role in
both criminal cases can rap lyrics be
used as evidence we're going to hear
from Lane's attorney Jose Baez and a
defense expert from the RICO trial
discussing the data and the dangers
foreign
[Music]
back everybody we have several Updates
this week in the worlds of crime and Hip
Hop one rap artist continues to fight
for a new trial out in Los Angeles while
another rapper's trial can't seem to get
off the ground in Atlanta let's start
off on the west coast hip-hop artist
Tory Lanez was convicted on felony gun
charges in December for the 2020
shooting of rapper Megan the stallion
while leaving a pool party she actually
ended up with shrapnel in her foot he
faces a maximum sentence of more than 22
years in prison that sentencing hearing
was initially scheduled for January but
it's been delayed several times as
Lane's got new attorneys for his case
his latest defense team filed a motion
for a new trial back in March with the
prosecution filing an opposing Motion in
early April the judge ultimately set a
hearing for May 8th to discuss it now if
a new trial is denied the judge expects
liens to be sentenced within 30 days of
the hearing this week we interviewed one
of Lane's new lawyers high-profile
defense attorney Jose Baez about why his
client deserves a second trial
one of them is is the DNA and the other
one are the rap lyrics
that uh were utilized against him the
rapper Persona and his creative art form
which I think is appalling that
prosecutors are are trying to use in in
this in many cases across the country so
it's a new movement to essentially try
to eliminate that type of evidence from
coming in because I I think it
racializes the proceedings
and utilizing rap persona
creative expression and rap lyrics is
puts the accused in a very
tough position
and I I think it's infiltrated by
extreme racism and she's never seen it
she should never see the inside of a
courtroom prosecutors basically used and
argued multiple times in his trial that
his he could not say his DNA was not on
the gun when the fact that's not true
his DNA was not on the gun his Pro they
didn't have a profile he wasn't even
considered a minor contributor and any
random African-American person from the
community
could have
could be a more likely contributor than
Tory Lanez on that gun and for someone
who allegedly shot the gun five times
and was recovered immediately
um I I find that to be incredibly
exploitatory especially in today's uh in
today's climate where jurors look for
DNA
as you just heard bias brought up the
use of rap lyrics in court and that
theme continues in our next case
involving Atlanta rapper Young Thug and
his alleged gang young slime life the
music artist is being tried alongside
more than a dozen other defendants on
gang-related charges but so far not a
lot of progress has been made jury
selection which started in January could
last into the summer as courtroom
disruptions have kept the jury box empty
proceedings have been held up by
everything from apps and jurors to
searches of the defendants in fact just
last week even a defense attorney ended
up in handcuffs causing his clients case
to be severed from the other
co-defendants but courtroom chaos aside
a hearing was held this week to qualify
a defense witness who says that he's an
expert on hip-hop lyrics and the alleged
connections to things like crime and
racism on the stand he was questioned by
both parties about a study he did on
stereotypes
when the lyrics were represented as rap
music compared to country or heavy metal
participants viewed the songwriter as
having worse character
and a greater criminal propensity right
than when those same lyrics or
categorized as country or heavy metal so
just changing the genre label
resulted in these different assumptions
about the character of the songwriter
you've never taken a course in evidence
no and you've never sat through and
watched a criminal trial correct yeah
you're saying that you are an expert in
crime
the stereotyping about race and rap
music and you have something to teach
yes
so Brian wrap lyrics they're being used
in both the YSL the lanes trial but are
they being used the same way and overall
do you think it's proper to use these
lyrics let me answer it backwards
overall I do not think it is proper as I
tell people no one tried to accuse Bob
Marley of shooting a sheriff or went
after Johnny Cash but there's a little
bit different the YSL lyrics are being
used as confessions character evidence
and of a crime bolstering the YSL gang
and their power and influence and it's
supported by circumstantial evidence for
Lanes they are used to prove the
ultimate question as to whether or not
the crime occurred and for Lanes more so
I think that shouldn't be used it should
be the jury and the evidence Audrey
evaluating the evidence to see whether
it occurred I understand bolstering
ysl's uh prominence in the community if
that is a part of your Ricoh charges but
the other charges associated with ysl's
music I think is horribly applied in
this case and as we've seen there's a
bias between one form of music and
others Terry bias brings up these two
arguments for Lanes to get a new trial
the rap lyrics the DNA evidence which do
you think stronger I think there both
strong but I think the rap lyric is is
probably a stronger argument look for
the DNA you can cross-examine someone
you can say that it shouldn't have been
you know included because it might not
have been his because of the odds and
the statistics but I don't think that
that is a large enough reason to win on
an appeal I do think the rap lyrics I
kind of agree with Brian but I don't
think they should be included in any way
shape or form it's an artistic
expression it has nothing to do with the
case it's not relevant I mean I think
the examples that Brian gave were great
but you know even if you look at a show
like how to commit a perfect murder if
you look at that show frankly what if
one of the actors was accused of a crime
and they use that against them it has
nothing to do with it all right slippery
slope we'll see